-Hey, guys, The Players
Championship was this weekend,
and we wanted to do
something fun with that,
so we gave a bunch
of the players weird phrases
and asked them to sneak those
phrases into their interviews
as casually as possible.
No one knew
we were gonna do this.
Here. Check it out.
It's time for "Drop It In."
-♪ Drop it in, drop it in ♪
♪ Droppa, droppa,
drop it in, yeah ♪
-Florida golf
and California golf.
Can you compare and contrast?
-Yeah, I mean, it's interesting.
This week, compared to when
we normally play this event,
it's more green, you know?
I'm used to it being
a little more bone-dry.
The rough just seems to be
sort of sweet sassy mollassy.
-Just talk a little bit
about how excited you are
to be back and also to have
the fans here this week.
-Well, yeah, you know,
I'm just corn dog
living a hot-dog life
out there now again.
-Now that we're at 20% capacity,
how much are you looking forward
to that aspect?
-Yeah, well,
you know, to be honest,
khakis with the pleats
and feet in their cleats
keep butts in their seats.
Um...
-Putting, you take
great pride in.
Could you talk a little bit
about that part of your game?
-Well, I love putting.
I'm a putt putt nut nut.
Can I get a what, what?
-I think I just learned that
you have to respect
the golf course.
There's trouble on every hole.
You can try to pin the tail
on the donkey,
but eventually you're gonna
get kicked in the teeth.
-I've never been known
to skip on the dip.
-Just curious --
your thoughts on the 17th,
of the tee shot,
if it's intimidating or not.
-Simple truth is...
you know, we have the meats.
We have what we need, you know?
You gotta go up there and be
great. It's as simple as that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Simple truth is...
we have the meats."
Oh, my goodness.
That was great.
Thank you to all the players
who helped us with that.